hello everybody
um we're super excited to be here and
share our years of experience in product
management and uh and companies so by
way of introduction just real quick
um my name is Donna novitsky I'm
currently the CEO of a startup company
called yifty y-i-f-t-e-e however I
started my career as a product manager
at Sun Microsystems which I think is the
best job in the world so congratulations
on making good choices
um went from there to uh running a
startup company that went public that
was living the Silicon Valley dream then
became a venture capitalist with a firm
called more David alventures on Sand
Hill Road
and after that went back to my startup
routes so basically everything I learned
about startups and bringing new products
to Market I learned in my first six
years as a product manager and that's
what I'm here to share today Laura hey
great to be here I'm Laura Marino I am
currently the chief product officer at
trumel that's a fintech company but I've
spent over 20 years leading product
teams in large and small organizations I
have been across Industries primarily in
B2B but again from large companies like
sap and Microsoft to smaller companies
and I would say that the area where I am
most passionate about is what I call
scale up these are companies that are
going through the high growth stage so
um a board member of a non-profit
promoting women in diversity and I've
been uh instructor at Stanford for many
years now
great so what we're going to talk about
is
um the transitions from starting with
very early on breathing life into your
very first products if any of you are
out there in startups or thinking about
startups this will be super useful
um and then moving from there to how to
accelerate time to volume by avoiding
all those things that you learn working
for big companies that really don't
apply to Young companies not just
startups but any uh bringing any kind of
new products to Market and then Laura's
going to talk about the five transitions
that startups have to go through in
order to scale and those product
challenges and then some broader
strategies for growth and expansive
expansion so there should be something
for everyone here and without further
Ado here we go so number one mistakes to
avoid while breathing life into your
first products
so uh
I call this
the tango it takes two to tango
what's going on here is she's saying
Follow My Lead I'm building the product
and he's saying Follow My Lead I'm
finding the customers and market and the
reality is you have to be doing both my
experience in venture capital I saw so
many entrepreneurs that were thinking
all they had to do was build the product
and they were 100 focused on building
that product well the field of dream
strategy if we build it they will come
does not work so we're going to talk
about how do you build the market at the
same time as you're building your first
products
but it's really hard you do not what you
have is your Rockstar team your exciting
product plans your vision but you don't
have a product you don't have customers
you don't have a reputation nobody knows
who you are so how do you get those very
first customers how do you get it off
your startup your young company off the
ground
you have to use what you have to get
what you don't have
so but first there's a mindset that you
need to have in order to be successful
not only at this stage but at every
stage so my question for you is what do
customers care about
so
they care about prices they care about
functionality they care about quality
these are the answers I usually get but
really it's bigger than that customers
care about themselves
so what you need to do is put yourself
in your customers shoes at all times
whether you're tiny whether that whether
you're a large company you need to
demonstrate that you comprehend the
customer's problem you are competent to
solve or realize that opportunity and
that you care because in the end if
you're a startup nobody knows anything
about your product there is no product
there is no Market there is no
reputation so it's you have to convince
them that you understand where they're
coming from
so how do we do that we're going to talk
about that but I'm going to use this
diagram to illustrate some of the points
that we'll be making
so I'm sure many of you come from the
product development side of the house
and you're pretty familiar with the the
typical product development process
although this is vastly simplified I
know so your ideas start out on a
whiteboard you build something you debug
it you get it ready for production
product goes live and eventually you
roll it out right okay no big news there
but what you need to be doing on the
marketing side is having these
exploratory meetings so when someone
when you're conceptualizing your product
ideating your product you need to be
talking to customers and finding out
what are their issues what are their
opportunities and how does your idea
your Concepts stack up against what's
going on in their real world
the next stage is going through
debugging and beta so everybody
understands when I send my product out
for beta testing I need to get feedback
on the product that's not enough you
need to also be building credibility
with those customers because if they
don't trust you if you are not credible
they're not going to buy your product
and then you go to having paying
customers you're not going to get those
paying customers for your first products
if you haven't built that credibility
and that belief that you understand
their Pro their issues from there you
you need to make sure that those initial
paying customers are referenceable
because that's how you're going to grow
you're going to build on those initial
customers to get more like them and then
you have a market
so we're going to use this is all pretty
obvious right I'm sure if I ask you guys
these questions you would say yeah this
is of course what we're going to do so
like what is she telling me what's new
here so rather than talk about that
anymore I'm going to talk about all the
mistakes that people made and we're
going to focus on these first two
there's lots of others we could spend an
entire class an entire course covering
the mistakes that product managers make
in bringing products to Market but we're
not going to do that we're just going to
talk about these first two you need to
make sure that you're building your
Market early on and that and you need to
also think about how you do that and
what is your early customer testing
process so where people go wrong where
entrepreneurs go wrong where product
managers go wrong is they go great I had
this idea the VCS love me my executive
management love me they gave us funding
to build this product I'm going to go up
and I'm going to build that product I'm
going to build that Vision we're going
to make it real what's wrong with this
if you have that kind of mindset and
you're not thinking about the market
you're going to either build too much
you're going to build the wrong stuff or
you're going to deliver too late so this
is where this concept of a minimum
viable product comes in which I'm sure
you're all familiar with because
everyone has read about MVPs and things
about MVPs now but that again that's not
sufficient what you have to also be
doing early on is figuring out how do
our customers make purchase decisions
where does my product fit in their
hierarchy of needs and who are going to
be my early Partners to build my uh
paying cut to get paying customers to
get references and to build my market am
I going to end up in the right Market if
I have these customers
so those are the things you need to get
right building the product vision is the
danger zone
so again if you do this wrong if you
just go out and build the product
without a lot of customer input your
engineering department says okay great
here's the product go get me some
customers this was fairly common in the
early days at Sun Microsystems when I
worked there and Sun can get away with
it or could get away with it at the time
because they already had customers they
had a reputation they had a market
people would buy the new product if
you're a young company a startup this is
what happens you go back to those
exploratory meetings you you go back to
get getting that customer feedback
Incorporated in your product and it can
cost you six to eighteen more months of
development time and that could be a
round of funding
so it could mean well the bigger
companies can get away with it brand new
startups cannot you may not have that
funding to redo the that product so what
do you do to address this problem how do
you get these early on meetings with
customers or potential customers I would
say if you're doing a B2B product you
need to meet with at least 30
prospective customers over a period of
three months
while in parallel with the product being
developed and if you're doing a consumer
product it's more than that so you're
thinking about during this process not
just what are the features and functions
that it needs to be but what's going on
with my potential customers where does
my product rank in their priorities
what's what are the greatest pains that
are that they have or what how does this
opportunity fit for this business if
it's a B2B company
who makes budgeting decisions we had a
one of the startups that I worked in
when I was a VC I had a great product
for
um email
administrators and so we tested it and
built relationships with lots of email
administrators they loved it and so we
brought this product to Market and the
email administrators couldn't get the
budget to buy the product that is
because when you talk to the CFO email
Administration was not on the high
priority list of things to fund in the
company so if you're not asking for
money for your early testers you're not
going to have all the information that
you need to be successful does that make
sense
so the whole decision making and
prioritization process of what's going
on with your customers is important not
just the features and functions of your
product
so how do you do that because you don't
even have a product to show them yet how
do you get these meetings what is it
that um that you do in order to learn
what you need to learn about the market
so remember I said you need to use what
you have to get what you don't have what
you have is a rockstar team someone on
your team is what I call the player it's
this guy it's the person that can make
that unbelievable shot so probably a
number of you are players and could play
this role in your company but it's
basically someone that can be marketed
in lieu of a product for example I
worked in a supply chain company when I
was a VC that company uh the CEO of that
company had many years of experience
with Deloitte and was billed out at 600
an hour was a true supply chain expert
so people really wanted to talk to him
customers potential customers really
wanted to talk to him tell him their
problems get his advice on how to fix
them
and so we went out we met with our 30
customers over three months we got a lot
of great feedback you have to watch out
with players sometimes they like to talk
and your goal here is to listen
so you're gonna this these are the
characteristics of a player
um but the big thing is you are
listening you are not talking you are
gathering information you are not
selling You're Building relationships
and credibility
that's what's important because the
player's expertise has more value to
your first customers and less risk than
your product so this player has
basically got to convince the customers
that he or she comprehends the problem
is competent to address it and cares
about these customers and they are
betting on that person not the product
when they make those purchase decisions
think about that
so number two how to accelerate
time to volume by avoiding the big
company beta test process I'm sure that
a number of you like I I brought 17 new
products to Market at Sun over a period
of three years so I was constantly going
through beta testing process I was
constantly doing product launches I was
constantly cranking out new products and
we had a process and the process looks
something like this we identified who
will test this product who will do us
this quote favor of testing the product
they need they would go out they would
identify features quality issues we
would get that feedback we would refer
it prioritize it we would refer it to
engineering engineering would make the
changes uh and then the pair in parallel
the company was learning how to deliver
how to support the product just
everything that you needed to be to
bring a successful product to Market but
at that time it wasn't we weren't really
thinking about is this customer this
tests are going to buy the product or
not they may buy it they may not buy it
they gave us the feedback that's what we
wanted
so then we finalized the product and we
launched the product so if you're doing
things this way I want to tell you or
get everything about how you do this it
is wrong for startups why is that
because this is the this is the another
where mistake where entrepreneurs go
wrong when they bring new companies to
Market they've been very successful at
other companies and you know previous to
their startup they're on big company
autopilot they know how to launch
products maybe they launch 17 products
like I did they know the process what's
wrong with this process is that they are
doing insufficient strategic customer
and Market qualification up front and
they're not focused on those early beta
testers becoming referenceable
what you have to get right is you have
to be very strategic about choosing who
are going to be my early testers
because 80 percent of them have to
actually pay money for this product
remember all those things we need to
learn from the player you need to
understand how purchasing decisions are
made where the money comes from so if
you don't ask for money you're not going
to learn all that and it's crucial
so why is this important why is it
different in a startup because the big
company already has products they have a
market they have reputation they have
existing customers startups again I'm
talking about breathing life into first
products they do not they don't have any
of that stuff it completely changes the
game
so your early product testing process is
the first time that your vision is being
tested before the true judge the
customers the customers have to love
your product they have to uh buy your
product it has to lead to additional
sales and it has to have those
additional sales in the right market so
that word of mouth leads you to a large
Market opportunity or else you go back
to ground zero in Market development and
or your Market is too small so here's my
Tango slide and for an example you go
through your whole process and you end
up with a market that's just not
interesting
so I've personally experienced I've
personally fallen for this trap
um it's easy to fall into
so what you have to do is make sure
you're not choosing wrong customers a
lot of people think you know is there a
wrong customer what would a wrong
customer be a wrong customer is a
customer in the wrong Market their
priorities are not mainstream and the
customer has no intention of buying
so a customer in the bottom line is a
wrong customer is a customer who is not
referenceable your early product testing
establishes those relationships it's the
groundwork for building your the rest of
your product line or in a company and if
you don't make good choices if you're
not thinking strategically you will end
up starting all over again
so the early product testing
um the obvious you must get feedback on
the product everyone knows that but you
also must select strategic customers and
establish them as Die Hard loyal
customers so that you can build on top
of that start
and with that I will turn it over to
Laura
perfect so we're going to talk about the
five transitions that startups must
Embrace to scale but let's start by
asking like why are transitions needed
in the first place
and when you think of companies
companies typically go through three
stages an early stage like this early
startup stage
uh scale up or high growth stage that I
like to call the teenage stage and we'll
talk about why and then uh in adult
stage so during the early stage the
company is still searching for product
Market fit trying different things to
see what actually resonates with the
market is looking for a repeatable
business model and it's doing the team
it's a team that essentially is doing
whatever it takes to get the product to
Market to secure those very valuable
early adopters that are going to help be
a reference
in the adult stage are grown-up startups
uh they might have gone through a
liquidity event they might have gone
through IPO or be part of an M A and
these are companies that are growing now
through a more repeatable process they
are more sort of permanent organizations
that are executing against a proven
business Market
and then you have this um in between
stage this
a stage where the company is no longer
looking for product Market fit what they
are trying to do is scale to grow the
number of customers or consumers at a
rate and in a way that will eventually
allow them to be cash flow positive and
really take over this Market where they
found that product Market fit
and it is a completely different ball
game than that early stage that we were
talking about and in reality uh about 60
percent of companies that successfully
exit this early stage with a good
product with product Market fit end up
failing in this teenage stage and I call
it the teenage stage because when you
think for a second about what teenage
years are like there's a lot of
opportunity but there's a lot of
uncertainty there's a lot of awkwardness
there is a lot of insight and I think
that it Maps very well to what companies
in this stage are going through
and to understand why the stage is so
difficult
we need to go back to look at what why
well it turns out that the early stage
strategies that help those startups get
to this product Market fit do not scale
and if we go back and look at what those
strategies are is we know companies need
to move fast test and iterate they may
even have to Pivot because they are
still not sure what is the right product
for the market that they are targeting
they have a team that can wear many hats
everybody is doing whatever it takes to
get that product out to Market and to
make sure that they can get those first
paying customers
communication in the company is very
informal and that allows for a lot of
agility but because it's a small team uh
people are all aligned they know what
they're going after
and you will have those people who are
the experts whether it's the founder the
first engineer they are the ones who
know everything about the product and
about the business but because the team
is small this tribal knowledge is easily
distributed
however as you start the high growth and
you're bringing thousands of new uh
customers and hundreds of new employees
this approach becomes totally chaotic
and it doesn't scale
so what are the changes what are those
transitions that those startups need to
embrace when they get to the scale up
stage and there are five key Transitions
and I'm going to focus primarily on the
third one that's moving from early
product to scalable product because
here's where we're going to be talking
about what are the biggest challenges
from the product perspective during high
growth and I'm going to talk about the
last two ones moving from ownership to
partnership and moving from being
opportunistic to being strategic because
this is where we're going to talk a bit
about what are the strategies the
product strategies for scaling and
expanding
however because product touches
everything in a company
I'm also going to talk about the first
two transitions because we as product
people need to be involved in all of
them
so the first transition is moving from
people to process
and if you're part of a startup you
probably know that process is
essentially a bad word you say process
in a startup and it's like oh no we're
going to become all of our bureaucratic
but again the reality is that in the
early stage you're going to have those
people who are the players who are the
ones who know everything about the
business and about the product itself
and about the customers
you may have
um the situation where everything needs
to go through a couple of those people
well when the company starts scaling
those people and that tribal knowledge
that they have becomes an obstacle to
grow
so what do you need to do the first
thing you need to do is embed that
expertise is that knowledge of those
unique people into the processes and the
structure of the country and that means
starting to do better documentation and
that's across the board from the HR
processes to documenting the code so
that as you bring on new Engineers they
kind of know what's what they're
touching you need to start creating more
training programs and uh new onboarding
you are going to be hiring a lot of
employees you need to have a process to
get them up to speed fast and to get
them a consistent story of what the
company is what the product is and you
will start seeing role specialization
roles that did not exist in a startup
that become more important when you
start scaling up and that could be sales
operations it could be legal but the
company needs to start really looking at
what are the things that these people
wearing 10 heads were doing that now
need to kind of get their specialized
team
you also need to create more formal
communication cases again remember the
communication can be very informal when
you're a small company but to keep
people aligned as the company grows you
need to proactively communicate and
that's communicating about the business
goals about the progress but also from
the product perspective is communicating
about growth it's very typical that in a
startup that there's no formal roadmap
there's no formal communication of what
the product team is doing because
everybody kind of knows they're all kind
of involved in like what's the next
thing we're going to try but once you've
gone to product Market fit and you're
evolving this product and you're growing
a team you need to let them know what's
coming you need to let your sales team
know what is coming you need to help
your marketing team know what they need
to be ready to present because if you
don't sales will come up with their own
version of what's coming and that can be
very very dangerous
and something else that's culture and
it's not something that's obvious to
people but the culture of a startup is
given by the founders and the founders
when they start the company they have a
vision of what are the values that they
want to have as part of that company and
that uh or the distributes organically
very easily when the company is small
when the company grows there has to be
an effort to make sure that those that
culture those values really get
distributed to all the new employees and
that's done by doing it the way in the
which the company recruits how
performance is evaluated and rewarded
and how the each employee treats the
other employees
so the second transition is moving from
relationship to breath again you heard
Donna talk about the players in the
early stage especially if you are in a
B2B company there's going to be a couple
of people who are the ones who need to
be in front of every potential new
customer because they are the only ones
who can explain truly the value that the
company is bringing you will have the
engineer who knows everything there's to
know about the product uh and he may
need to be pulled into so when you are
scaling this sales that has been based
on relationships from the player from
the CEO really need to transition to a
brand you want a brand that's recognized
in the market that communicate to the
market what
um that the company is bringing and so
for that this is the time it's really
important to start maturing your
marketing and sales organization it's
important that you start bringing people
who understand demand generation if
you're in b2c bringing people understand
social media marketing so that now the
brand of the company is understood in
the market and it is a really important
period for uh bringing sales especially
in B2B starting to Define what's going
to be the sales strategy and enabling
sales sales enablement and product
marketing become absolutely critical
because again you're not going to have
all of those players
in every single sale so every
salesperson needs to have the tools and
the understanding to be able to come
explain the value to position the
product correctly
and again product is quite involved in
helping with the sales enablement and
with product marketing
but now we really get to the core of
where the product people need to be
watching out for Transitions and uh this
is moving from early product to scalable
product and this is where we really need
to watch out for biggest challenges now
notice that I'm not talking about moving
from MVP to scalable product because
when a company gets to the scale-up high
growth stage they're way past MBT they
already have a product that has proven
that has value in the market and it has
a referenceable customers and now it's
really about scaling it to a much much
larger number of customers
so again to understand why there are
going to be challenges in this stage
let's go back and revisit how product is
developed and evolved in the early stage
again we are in the early stage the
product team in engineering they need to
move fast and iterate
and Engineering is not worried about
building anything scalable in fact
engineering
is almost encouraged to do shortcuts and
hooks so that they can get something to
Market as fast as possible so that it
can be validated and it can be inter
iterated
on
um the focus is on producing features
capabilities that are visible to those
customers you want to show value so that
those customers actually start saying
yes I'm willing to pay for this so
there's no time and no attention to
building tools in the back that would
enable an implementation team or a
technical support team to support those
clients and then you are really trying
to secure those early adopters those
key customers who will help you evolve
the product and who will be those
references and because it's so important
to ensure that you secure them you will
be willing to accommodate some unique
things that they may want to have as
long as they really are helping you
build the product for the market
so if your product were a building by
the end of that early stage your product
might look something like this
it would have
um a bunch of pretty customer specific
functionality that you built to
accommodate those key initial customers
and even if you had built it in a way
that could be used by others you kind of
know that that was stuff that was sort
of unique for those uh very important
customers
you will have pieces of this building
that are very uh built very poorly
these are the hacks and shortcuts that
engineering was doing in order to get
something out to Market very fast
now the foundation will probably be very
weak and not ready to take on a lot of
new volume a lot of new customers again
you were focusing on building the stuff
that could be seen you were not focused
in your engineering team on scalability
now you will also have and this is
especially true in B2B oh this is what
we typically call technical debt but
there's another piece of technical did
that you may have and again in B2B there
will be a piece of your product that is
never finished that seems to always need
engineering work ongoing and this is the
part of the product that engineering
needs to touch every time you secure a
new client because they have not built
the tools or the apis that will enable a
Professional Services organization to
take over and Implement and configure
the product for every new client I also
call that part of technical dip
so why is it that this problems existed
in the early stage but why is it that
they become a really big concern when
you're scaling up so let's first look at
what is the cost of this customer
specific functionality again you
securing those early important customers
is absolutely critical and it's okay for
you as a product manager in that early
stage to accommodate some of those
unique things as long as you can get
those customers on board but the problem
is now those customers are accustomed
that they tell you what they want and
you will go and build it and as you
start scaling that is a problem because
those customers can start taking over
the road and you really need to be
involving your product to serve the
market
so you're going to have to start
learning to say no to those customers
and it's not easy because again they've
been accustomed to getting what they
want so here are a couple of strategies
and tips on how to say no the first
thing is to proactively communicate to
those customers what you're doing and
why if those customers believe that your
roadmap is sort of a blank sheet of
paper for them to start filling in they
will be getting all the list of things
that they want you but if you
proactively go to them and say these are
the things we're working towards and
this is why at a minimum they realize
that hey you are working on stuff you're
not just waiting for them to tell you
what to do
the other thing you can do in this was
very successful I worked for Intel and
it was a company that was focusing on
the largest
uh legal companies in the U.S UK
Australia and Canada
and you can imagine that every single
one of those large law firms felt that
they were the most important customer
that we could ever have and they all had
their own list of things that they
wanted us to do so we started bringing
them together in customer Council we
would group together uh law firms that
consider themselves peers
we would uh ask them to share with us
what their main challenges were and we
would share with them the direction we
were going and it was very interesting
to see one of those customers that had
been pounding their fists saying you
absolutely need to build this realize
that their peers didn't care at all
about that part of functionality so that
was really helpful for them all to
realize that we're actually building a
product for not for each of them
individually
but
every everything else fails you need to
be prepared to say no and what that
means is you need to go to your
Executives and your CEO and tell them
why it is that you don't want to
accommodate these request from this big
customers what are the trade-offs that
the company would have to have to
accommodate it what would be all those
things that would not get done
and the reason you need to align your
Executives and your CEO with that is
because that customer is going to
escalate to the CEO they will have a
direct line to the CEO so you want the
CEO to be aligned and prepared to say no
I had in one of my companies actually
have even more extreme case we had a big
big logo customer and sales was excited
that we had this big logo because now
they could go and sell to these other
big whales but when I came in it was
clear that we were spending a lot of
engineering and product resources
addressing things that were absolutely
unique to that customer so I finally uh
spent time with engineering and product
we laid out in detail how much time we
were spending on building stuff that was
not reusable for anybody else and I was
able to go to the executive team and I
presented the 2010 of all of our
engineering and product were going to
build stuff that was not reused and that
if we were to land another way like that
we were just going to become a custom
development shop and with that uh we had
to make the right decision to part ways
with that customer and it was the right
thing to do it was painful but it was
the right thing to do
so the next
um Big Challenge is uh technical debt
and why is it that we have technical
debt and no tools well every startup at
the end of that uh early stage should
have some technical debt because if you
had started building everything to be
fully scalable and you had started
building everything so that the tools
were there for Professional Services and
support you would have run out of money
way before getting your first product
out and you would have fallen in one of
the mistakes that Donna was describing
of building too much so it's natural
it's okay to have technical debt when
you uh start the scale-up stage but if
you don't start now paying attention to
it it really can hurt you in its most
benevolent way technical debt will start
slowing you down engineering will have a
hard time building functionality on top
of pieces of the code that are fragile
that are poorly built and so everything
will become slower to build but in a
more pernicious way technical debt
becomes visible to your customers and
that can actually take you down there
was a company way before Facebook even
before
um Myspace called friendsters
and they built a social network and they
were being very successful and all of a
sudden they got all this success
everybody wanted to sign up for their
service everybody wanted to be on their
service and their product could not
scale and it completely started failing
and cons
were not forgiving they would not come
back to see maybe two might seem better
completely lost it so it is very
important for you to start addressing
technical debt so how do you go about it
the first thing you need
location in the early stage when you're
first starting your first product you
probably can spend ninety percent of
your engineering bandwidth on building
new functionalities because only a small
piece will go to fixing things that are
breaking or helping with those early
implementations or maintaining what
you've uh functionality that you put out
because you're just starting with things
but as you your product grows in
complexity is the number of clients grow
you need to start realizing that a lot
of your engineering bandwidth now has to
go to other things
maintaining the stuff that was built
already because guess what there's no
single feature that's fully built in
version one so if you put some new
functionality you better be sure that
you're going to have to maintain and
improve it you need to start addressing
that technical debt
you need to start building those
implementation tools that will allow
engineering to not have to be involved
in every implementation and you need to
have more bandwidth for things that
break and because there's going to be
more clients and more things to bring
and if you don't proactively plan for
that the reality is going to force you
in that direction in an ugly way when I
joined one of the companies uh that I
worked for Topia and they had a very
complex platform for helping large
companies relocate employees
um when I joined I knew that the
previous VP of product had been fired
and when I started talking to the
executives what they said was like
product and engineer kept promising
things and they never delivered
so I started looking at what was going
on what what was going on is that
product and Engineering we're thinking
that their capacity was still in the
left side like they that 90 of their
time they were just going to be building
all this new stuff and they were
promising all this new stuff but the
reality is that by then the company
already had some big customers and
Engineering kept being pulled into
things that were breaking into helping
new implementations because they had to
go and set up things in the database and
in uh maintaining stuff that they had
delivered and that customers were saying
yes but I wanted to work different and
they had not realized it so they kept
promising stuff they couldn't have time
to deliver so I actually had to go back
and reset the expectations and so how do
you go about doing that the first thing
you need to do is you need to partner
with engineering to figure out what are
the pieces that are going to break
and then you have to prioritize
paying for technical debt
re-architecting those pieces that are
most likely to break and you put them as
part of the roadmap because it's the
same engineering team and then you
communicate proactively to sales and to
the executives why why is it so
important that you slow down on new
functionality and instead take some time
to improve fix rebuild pieces that the
product needs to stay
um so this is really important this is
something that every person who's going
through this stage anything product
needs to be thinking about now the next
one is moving from ownership to
partnership and uh in the early stage
companies really want to control
everything they want to control the
interaction with the consumers but if
you scale There's an opportunity for you
to be smarter as to where you use your
resources Partnerships can come in
different flavors you can have partners
that help with Market Market access that
they resell your product or refer your
product you can have Partners who do the
services so your product needs
implementation it's great to have
Partners who do their Professional
Services but you need to have provided
the tools and the apis for that and then
there's the technology and here's where
you as the product leader or product
manager need to start thinking where do
I put my precious engineering resources
to improve the areas that are
differentiating and where could I just
uh build a partner or buy for our areas
that are important but are not key and a
very good example we have used is
embedding things like a BMI tool you
don't want your engineering team to all
of a sudden be pulled into building a bi
tool when your core product is a
recruiting platform but if your
customers really want to slice and dice
the data in every way possible you can
embed a VA tool that's just one of the
Excel and then the final transition
that you need to think when you're
trying to think about how to grow and
scale is moving from being opportunistic
to being strategic
and this actually has two components
that seem a little bit contradictory
focus and expansion
in the early stage companies are trying
different things to see what's stick and
they may be pivoting and they may try
this one thing and then another one but
once you get to product Market fit once
you find a market that you really want
to win you need to focus on that product
in that market
and you focus your execution on that and
you stop on things that were
distractions
but while you're doing that you need to
start thinking about expansion and that
is a thought process to start early on
because
no very few companies that start with
one product especially if they have VC
funding we'll get to the size that they
and their VCS expect with that just one
product so you need to start thinking
how is it that you're going to expand
and how is it that you are going to get
to the Future that you are and there's
strategies can vary you can say okay I'm
going to start now filling in a whole uh
family of products so I start with one
now I have those customers I can start
survey solving other problems for them
at Intel we did that we had started with
two little products for Niche products
for law firms and then we built an
entire uh Suite of products to serve all
of their rescules and then we expand it
to adjacent Industries because legal
wasn't large enough but there are other
strategies you can look at being
platform you can look at
internationalization being up or down
Market but you need to start thinking
about it as you are going through this
high growth scale-up stage
so those were the key things so Donna
you want to take us home
sure
um
so let's see Laura that was awesome
thank you uh for those uh hard learned
lessons I'm sure from The Real World
um so just to recap really quick here
um what we're saying is you need to be
building the market while you're
building the product or easier to
remember maybe it takes two to tango and
that your early testing customers are
going to determine who you're going to
be who your product line is going to be
make sure that they're the right
customers that you're strategic about
picking them and that they're going to
be referenceable and Laura you want to
cover your points sure I think that a
key thing for you to remember is you do
need to make a transition
and you should not be afraid you need to
embrace this change when you're starting
the scale-up stage and then just
remember you do need to be able to rein
in those early customers that you may
love very much but you need to not allow
them to take over and address technical
debt and then be focused but also start
planning for the future
all right so thanks everybody you have
the best jobs in the world
um I hope that what we're providing is
helpful to you and we'll look forward to
connecting if you want on LinkedIn
yes thank you so much Laura and Donna I
apologies to the audience for not having
time at the end for a q a
um I still hope you found this engaging
if you're interested in learning more
about product management you can visit
our website
online.stanford.edu to find more
information about our offerings and
product management and other topics so
thanks again to everyone